(upbeat music)
- Whoo!
- Oh!
- [Girl with Bun] Tostilocos.
- Looks like a party.
- This looks spicy.
- They look like some (bleep) up nachos,
but in the best (bleep) up way possible.
- Is there fruit and what's this?
- What is this?
- Is that meat?
- It's like a tamarind candy.
- Very flavorful.
- Oh!
- This is dope, this is great.
- Oh, my God!
- [Man] Whoo!
It's like a flavoring punch in the face.
- This is a myriad of texture.
- Just when it didn't feel fuzzy.
(laughs)
- I keep getting the most
pungent extreme parts.
- I think it's just the whole thing.
- It is?
- [Man] Probably.
- Hmm!
- That looks yummy.
- It does look pretty yummy.
- Oh, it looks so good, I love cheese.
- I love cheese, too.
(laughs)
- I like the mayonnaise.
I like the mayonnaise and cheese
but not the hot sauce.
- I like the hot sauce and the cheese
but not the mayo. (laughs)
- I think the mayonnaise,
a lot of people are afraid
of the mayonnaise, I think it works.
- I definitely had the
white people version of this
at Six Flags where they
just put butter on it.
- This is a win, five out of five.
- I normally don't like corn on the cob
but having all these flavors
in it, it's totally worth it.
- Oh.
(laughs)
- Mangos.
- Party in a cup.
- Oh, mango!
- [Girl with Bun] Girl!
- Mango!
- Smells very good.
- Smells like a dessert.
- Mmm, oh! (bleep)
(laughs)
- It's like a slimy Warhead.
- [Girl] Mm-hm.
- Mm-hm.
- This looks like a beef jerky stick.
- (laughs) Oh, my God!
It's so strong.
- [Man] It's very,
very strong.
- I don't know what to do with myself.
- Ah, my mouth is on fire.
- You bite this guy,
then you get a little bit of that.
- It's not so bad when
you take it with mango
and then that.
- It's not bad, though.
- You like it?
- I do (laughs).
- Smells like horchata.
Is it horchata?
- [Girl] Ooh, it's warm.
- Looks kinda chalky but
it smells really good.
(cups clink)
- That is thick.
- It's kinda like a
melted ice cream texture.
- It kinda does.
I think that's why I like it.
- This is champurrado, right?
- Champurrado.
- [Purple Haired Girl] Ooh!
- It's like the beginnings of a chai latte
but it didn't quite get there.
- I don't know, it almost
looks kinda chunky.
Like somebody was eating a cookie.
(laughs)
- That's the masa.
Sometimes champurrado is a
little bit too sweet, not my type
but this is pretty good.
- After eating Cinnamon Toast Crunch,
using the milk and then microwaving it.
- Yes, that's exactly what it's like.
- If it's colorful and vibrant
and smells good, like, eat it.
- That's why we're friends.
- Right.